PERHAPS THE MOST POPULAR
IS RUNNING A FUNERAL HOME,
AND WITH PEOPLE DYING
DAILY
FROM EVERYTHING
FROM HEART ATTACKS
TO COLLAPSING
DURING A STOCK PHOTO SHOOT,
THE FUNERAL BUSINESS
HAS NEVER BEEN MORE PROFITABLE.
JUST ASK CANDY BOYD.
SHE'S BEEN RUNNING
BOYD FUNERAL HOME
IN LINWOOD, CALIFORNIA,
FOR OVER 15 YEARS,
AND TODAY,
I PAID HER A VISIT
WITH AN IDEA TO MAKE
HER BUSINESS EVEN BETTER.
UNBEKNOWNST TO CANDY,
I WENT BY THE NIGHT BEFORE
IN MY USUAL DISGUISE
TO SCOPE THINGS OUT,
BUT MY BEARD
WAS COMING LOOSE,
SO I WAS TOO AFRAID
TO GO INSIDE,
SO I ENDED UP JUST
CHECKING OUT THEIR WEBSITE
TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
SO BASICALLY,
YOUR BUSINESS IS DEATH.
- CORRECT. CORRECT.
- AND THAT MUST BE
BITTERSWEET FOR YOU.
- I MUST SAY, IT IS.
- BITTER BECAUSE PEOPLE DIE...
- RIGHT.
- AND SWEET...
- BECAUSE
YOU'RE MAKING MONEY.
- EXACTLY, EXACTLY.
- SO IT'S HARD,
BECAUSE YOU MAYBE GET EXCITED
WHEN SOMEONE DIES.
- RIGHT, EXACTLY.
- BECAUSE YOU'RE LIKE,
"I'M GONNA PROFIT FROM THIS..."
- RIGHT, EXACTLY, EXACTLY.
- BUT IT'S SAD BECAUSE, "OH..."
- EXACTLY, EXACTLY.
- THEY'RE, LIKE, LOSING.
- EXACTLY.
- SO IT'S A BALANCE.
- IT'S A BALANCE.
- MONEY WAS CLEARLY
IMPORTANT TO MRS. BOYD,
AND I SAW SHE WAS MISSING OUT
ON SOME PROFITABLE SERVICES
TO OFFER HER CUSTOMERS.
THE PLAN--I WANTED HER
TO GIVE PEOPLE
THE OPTION
OF BUYING MORE FRIENDS.
- BUYING MORE FRIENDS?
- BASICALLY,
WHEN YOU DIE,
YOU WANT TO HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE
COME TO YOUR FUNERAL,
BECAUSE IT SHOWS
THAT YOU'RE WELL-LIKED.
- CORRECT.
- SO I THINK YOU SHOULD
GIVE PEOPLE THE OPTION
OF PAYING FOR ACTORS
TO BE FAMILY OR FRIENDS
AT A FUNERAL.
- OH, I SEE, I SEE.
- LIKE, TO FILL THE ROOM.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
- YEAH.
- AND IT COULD BE
A VERY PROFITABLE ADD-ON SERVICE
TO OFFER TO PEOPLE.
- WELL, I MEAN,
IT IS PRETTY INTERESTING.
I DON'T KNOW--
- I'D LOVE TO DEMONSTRATE
FOR YOU WHAT IT MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
- OH, SURE. THAT'D BE GREAT.
-AND MAYBE THAT WOULD
HELP SELL IT TO YOU.